hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well the ancient stone
school devoted a lot of their resources
and time to analysis of arguments not
just for its own sake but in order to
apply these practically to life and not
to be taken in by bad argumentation it's
part of their important practice they
call this domain logic and they made
some very important contributions to it
Epictetus themself does talk about the
value of logic and I've done a few
videos that you can see talking about
that but he also talks about the need to
work on practical matters as well and
one of the interesting arguments that's
going to come up is a sorehead cracker
from the ancient period a lot of people
exercise themselves on in took positions
on and it's called master arguments now
Epictetus himself is going to say two
interesting things I'm going to reserve
one of them for the end but before we
get to that in an earlier chapter in
chapter 18 19 is where you're going to
find the master argument articulated
he's going to talk about a situation a
real life problem that is
in fact Huffer he says then the master
argument so let me actually run you
through that very quickly this is one
dealing with practical reasoning today
when I saw a handsome laughter handsome
woman I did not say to myself wouldn't
that a man when I sleep up there and her
husband is a happy man for the man who
uses the expression happy the husband
means happy is the adulterer also I do
not even picture myself the next scene
the woman herself and my presence just
roaming and lying down by my side I put
myself on the head say well done
Epictetus you have solved the clever
problem one much more clever than the so
called master argument so he's saying
when we encounter our life's
difficulties and we work our way through
them and we get to the right solution
we're doing something that as difficult
if not more difficult than this master
argument that we're going to see and
then he says when the wench is not only
willing but not to be incensed for me
yes and when she even lays hold on me
and snuggles up to me if I still hold
aloof and conquer this has become a
solved problem greater than the liar and
the quiescent on this score a man has a
right to be proud indeed but not about
is proposing the master problem so epic
juice is saying what we really ought to
take pride in is not so much you know
figuring out answers to these these more
abstract puzzles but how do we can port
ourselves when we're in situations that
call for some pretty serious and robust
and consistent practical reasoning now
all that said let's look at the argument
as he does lay it up because he doesn't
say oh well it's totally useless to look
at he says let's actually discuss it he
says the master argument appears to been
propounded on the strength of some such
principles as the following so he's
giving us his interpretation there seems
to be a contradiction so I'm sort of as
he calls it a massive battle between
these three propositions now when you
look at these propositions you see the
throne of great generality there
physical propositions we would say they
have to do with issues of what nowadays
philosophers call mortality necessity
possibility impossibility and in fact
mobile logicians have sometimes played
around with this here's the three
propositions that can't all fit together
so the different people who look at them
have to make a decision which one am I
going to reject and everything true is a
past event is necessary and it has to be
the way it is right because it's past
you can't change the past that's one and
impossible does not follow from a
possible something that can be doesn't
follow from something that in fact can
make that's what it means to be possible
you know I do not Sami and Greek then
the third one is what it's not true now
and never will be is nevertheless
possible now that one that also seems to
be something we can get behind because
it's saying you know that there could be
some things that aren't true and never
are going to be true but they could have
been the case right or in some alternate
imagined universe maybe they are the
case and so if we think these through we
see that they don't all fit together
like those different scholars have
argued for two of these picking two of
these against the other and it tells us
a little bit about that there's three
different groups that do that do Doris a
great you know ancient thinker says
realizing this contradiction use the
plausibility the two propositions these
first two propositions to establish the
principle nothing is possible which is
neither true now nor that will ever be
so that's one way you reject a third and
say there aren't any possible things
that aren't the case or that won't be
the case another possibility is to say
something is pop here we go
something is possible which is not true
and will never be and impossible does
not follow impossible and
they don't grant that everything true as
an event to the past is necessary they
need to deny that clay at these and
other people took that that tact and
then a third way is to say a thing is
possible which is not true now that
never will be so accept the third
proposition and everything true as an
event in the past is necessary but then
they say an impossible does follow a
possible and he says you can't maintain
all three of these propositions but
those are three different possibilities
you can take whichever one of them out
and saying that one doesn't work but
then the other two will work now which
one should we accept well
Epictetus says a lot of great ancient
thinkers have staked out positions on
this but if you ask him this is the
second thing I want to bring up if
somebody asks me which pair of these do
you yourself maintain I shall answer him
I do not know but I have received the
following account the odorous used to
maintain one pair path elitist and his
group and clan this another one at
cruciferous and his group the third but
none so he says well then what is your
opinion and he says I don't know
and I wasn't made to figure this one out
that's not the purpose that I was given
my mind for because nothing in terms of
practical rationality is actually going
to turn on solving this and as we you
know who we saw in the beginning he says
matters of practical reasoning when we
actually see them through to their
solution are much more worthy of our
time and attention than these you know
what we philosophers would say are
intriguing metaphysical problems or
paradoxes or conundrums so this is a
very important argument in the history
of logic and in the history of
philosophy the Stoics themselves the
great Stoics exercises themselves on it
but epictetus is going to say i
understand how it how its set up I'm not
going to
position